let's talk about this uh this first
story and uh we have this from cnn of
all outlets i like using cnn when it's
something like this white house responds
to russia's decision to put deterrence
forces on high alert
they say white house secretary jen
sackey said sunday that russian
president vladimir putin's decision to
put russia's deterrence forces which
include nuclear arms and high alert are
part of a wider pattern of unprovoked
escalation and manufactured threats from
the kremlin this is really a this is
really a pattern that we've seen from
president putin through the course of
this conflict which is manufacturing
threats that don't exist in order to
justify further aggression and the
global community and the american people
should look at it through the through
that prism sachi told abc's george
stephanopoulos on this week
well the news there is that in response
to the sanctions the escalation and i
guess what putin says is aggressive
language towards russia
they've put all of their uh forces on
high alert which includes nuclear
weapons and then you had this guy on
russian tv who said what's the point
something like what's the purpose of the
world without russia in it and then said
we've got 500 nuclear submarines we can
launch these warheads and you know we
could basically wipe out nato in the u.s
i guess the question is saber-rattling
hyperbole or should we all go hide in
the basement there's absolutely going to
be nukes dropped you think so hassan
[ __ ] just said there wouldn't oh
there we go my man's reversed
nostradamus we're screwed we're just
done for guys i want to launch them on
mars i think if you nuked the poles on
mars doesn't that start an atmosphere or
something do you think russia is that
that you know it's funny that maybe you
could work together yeah what's funny
about the north pole they can take the
south pole it has like one percent of
what of like relevance to the
conversation i know i'm just trying to
make it better i kind of you aren't
thinking about
the world
i hope there's the right place why would
anyone do it it seems like if you
launched a nuke that would be the be the
end of everything no i disagree the
surface you don't think the surface
would just get fried after that the u.s
did it they got away with this drop of
chicken that was before anyone else had
yeah that was before i see beyonce so
look the the fear is mutually assured
destruction right mm-hmm not real i
don't believe in it i don't think it's a
real thing
so you guys have to see that movie with
uh was it matthew broderick no war games
war games yeah and like all the missiles
are like flying in the air or whatever
and then there was gi joe you guys ever
see the gi joe
where
the guy who looks like the pope plays
the villain what
no i didn't see him yeah
the guy from game of thrones was the
priest guy who plays the villain and
then he's like the u.s fires their nukes
and then so then every other country is
like what are you doing and they all
fire the nukes and they see all the
nukes in the air and then the cobra guy
masquerading as the president blows up
the us nukes so that everyone else does
mutually sur destruction makes no sense
to me right let me ask you a question
lauren let me ask you a question
uh so a military officer comes to you
and he says
mrs southern
17 nuclear warheads are headed towards
the eastern seaboard there is nothing we
can do to stop them but
you can choose to kill 10 million
civilians yourself would you do it would
you be like i guess i'll blow up a bunch
of civilians
you know if i was a little more [ __ ]
and spiteful maybe but
you know maybe no no no well it depends
on how the patreon lawsuits well but
think about it yeah
it would be like which cities are we
talking about do i get to like and
choose let's just say you know like we
can russia has fired a bunch of uh nukes
at the eastern seaboard of the united
states uh vancouver and toronto included
i guess because you know canada um
you can't stop it but you can kill
russian civilians would you do it
i don't i don't think yeah i don't think
i don't know here's the thing i don't
know if she would but someone would yes
that's a good point i think that threat
exists in the mind of anyone who's
considering launching nukes in the first
place but you guys ever hear that story
about the russian submarine dude they
got a false alarm yes that nuke was
fired and he refused to fire the world i
think that's more indicative of what a
person would do
well there's been studies done on this
too with like just the amount of people
in war that go out whether it be
afghanistan or world war ii and they'll
talk about how much they freeze it's
like the first time it's almost like i'm
making this up on the spot fake stats
but it was something i read said like 50
of the time they'll freeze and not be
able to shoot someone the first time it
happens to them we talked about this
with someone with vietnam they were
saying that this the soldiers who were
drafted would aim up and try not to hit
people yes actually most soldiers there
was a study done called men under fire
and they basically found that something
like two percent of soldiers did 98 of
the killing whoa yeah and so the entire
idea was our government wanted to figure
out how you could get everyday average
troops to be willing to fight because
most people in a combat situation if
someone is up on top of them or they
have to kill them in a direct
self-defense scenario will do so so in
warfare if the enemy are jumping into
your trenches yes you'll shoot them more
often than not but if they're all the
way across the battlefield and you're
trying to snipe and pick them off most
soldiers won't pull the trigger and our
government kind of tried to
figure out ways to encourage troops to
do so didn't video games help
i'm not sure there's a game called
america's army that was basically
grooming people to become soldiers
not that um there's a misconception that
the government says
it makes you more violent
but when you're desensitized to entering
combat what i was reading something
where they said like playing video games
helped people overcome their like
resistance towards killing someone
i think probably with drones and stuff
it's a lot easier the further and
further like degrees apart it's almost
like the um trolley question
okay would you pull the thing to kill
one person or two people all right would
you push someone in front of the train
to stop the trolley the closer you get
to being the exact thing that kills the
person that's when all those mental
blocks start but when they're just green
light on a screen much easier to click a
button my favorite trolley meme is the
one where
it's one track and it's just riddled
with people and it says you can stop the
train at the trolley at any time but it
would hurt corporate profits
that one's good by the way it was also
it was men against fire was the name of
it men against five yeah and yeah so yes
um and i want to double check the
numbers i threw out i i may have
misremembered them so go and look that
up for yourself i got the name of this
shockingly low number of people are
willing to actually engage in this the
russian um submarine soldier his name
was vasily arkapov and it's during the
height of the cold war uh cuban missile
crisis and he got i think there was a
miscalculation they thought the nukes
had been fired he got an order to fire
and he didn't do it basically prevented
world war three that's one guy yeah and
he's like he's like a hero right yeah
they're like this guy i don't i don't i
don't think most people would do it but
would vladimir putin is a question and i
think vladimir putin would fire nukes if
he was fired on yeah no no i think he
would i think
yeah i think vladimir putin would launch
nukes really well look at they're not
really sending they're like people are
giving the ukrainians weapons but no
one's sending troops in they're kind of
just like oh we don't really want to get
involved we don't want to get in trouble
so he's
i don't know the man might get away with
it i saw a cartoon meme of the ukraine
guy and they're the american i was like
you have my gun and the other guy's like
you have my the scandinavian i was like
you have my axe and then the british guy
was like you have my bow and then it
shows the the ukrainian guy and he's
just got an axe a bow and a sword
yeah yeah lord of the lord of the rings
yeah uh also i just want to pull
something up real quick so i can uh add
some clarity what i was saying earlier
the best figures i have right now say
that according to the study it was fewer
than 15 to 20 of soldiers fired their
weapon in the first place and then an
even lower number actually killed people
but with my yeah no but i also want to
say with my number about two percent
actually doing 90 of the killing i'm
actually i'm not seeing that here i
imagine most soldiers aren't in combat i
believe most soldiers are doing like
logistics are back behind the scenes are
you talking about just combat soldiers i
believe well i mean i i believe that the
study is referring to combat soldiers
because that's the reason they would i
mean it's the entire reason they were
doing the research right
wow smackdown now sheamus giving me a
nice no i'm sorry i didn't no no no no
no no no no you could actually i could
be completely wrong i'm saying this is
what i'm a man
yeah so the question is why is vladimir
putin invading ukraine and if you can
answer that you can answer whether or
not he's willing to use nukes more
more accurately so there's a you know
there's the conspiracy theories they uh
maybe not even conspiracy is the right
word but there is the theory that
vladimir putin opposes the davos group
world economic forum liberal economic
order and all that stuff and
it's not an issue of nato which is
proven by the fact that estonia and
latvia are on the border with russia as
well and they're nato nations the issue
is that ukraine is you know joining the
liberal economic order or whatever and
putin's actually directly criticized
this
i don't actually think that's the
principal reason though if that was the
reason then you could argue well he's
got to stop the globalists so of course
he'll use nukes right there there are
people posting this there was a crazy a
ukrainian mp went on fox news and said
they're fighting for the new world order
and so yeah and so this is a lot of
people saying like that proves it i got
a really simple solution for all of you
guys the us and nato have been screwing
with russian oil profits
it's it's like kind of that simple right
yeah i'm not sure that russia care about
profits as much as we think they do i
think they've got especially in the east
they have different values than we do in
the west in a sense they've got those
blood and soil values more than we do
they've got the spiritual values they
genuinely believe like the ukrainians
are spiritually connected to russia i
interviewed a guy named michael
millerman really interesting case he's
got a phd on alexander dugan who they've
called uh putin's brain has a phd on
dugan it's it's in like eurasianism or
around that topic but he studied and
translated alexander dugan that was like
his focus of his work yeah and he had 12
professors helping him out with the phd
11 of them quit because they said this
is too dangerous you shouldn't be
allowed to study this topic it's
because he partakes in something called
strategic empathy where he really wants
to understand the russian perspective
and like
be able to empathize for the purpose of
understanding and everyone said no this
is disgusting how can you have such an
illiberal worldview and now he's getting
calls from all over the world of people
like what is going on please explain
eurasianism to us and he's
well then
that's the issue then if if uh you know
we mentioned ben shapiro's uh tweet he
said russia you know putin wants to
rebuild the empire yes sanctions aren't
going to deter someone who's
ideologically driven right if if putin
is driven by ideology i believe he he
can and will use nukes
i mean well maybe i shouldn't say will
he he's he's uh capable of he's what i
mean to say is he's the he's the kind of
person who i believe has the capability
and the uh willpower to put it i'm not
saying it's a good thing to press the
button and say i will get what i want
you know what i mean yeah people are
reasonable when they're driven by these
temporal things of you know money day to
day i just want to stay safe
but when you're at that higher level
where it's like even something like
revenge or this is a spiritual battle
then you get people that'll blow
themselves up in stadiums for it yeah
but i think you know uh to elaborate on
the profit motive thing i i'm not saying
it's like putin wants money and he's
like where's my money my oil it's more
like
getting resources for russia yeah i
agree with that so
you know what i see is we we've
mentioned it 50 million times you've got
the cutter turkey pipeline you've got
the the corrupt energy dealings joe
biden was doing in in in ukraine with
with why i should say his son and then
his intervention with the government and
putin's like look we we support the
russian people selling oil to our
customers in europe we charge what we
can charge the west doesn't like those
prices so they're playing dirty games
like funding uh funding or providing
resources to rebels in syria and then
playing dirty games with barisma joe
biden's on camera saying if you don't
fire the prosecutor not in the billion
dollars turns out the prosecutor was
investigating the founder of barisma
whereas someone's on the board conflict
of ventures at the very least putin's
like
you're screwing with my ability to
generate resources for my country and my
people so that's that's less of an
ideological and more of like uh looking
up you know a world leader thing
but i i wonder if it is more ideological
than well i i know i in it's difficult
to say i can't read putin's mind i think
there's an argument to be made that it
isn't ideological uh that it is more or
less from russia's standpoint a security
issue whereas from america's standpoint
it's an ideological issue so we see this
as we would like for
ukraine to become a more liberalized
nation which is part of nato
and which is part of the eu and from
putin's perspective it's as soon as they
become a nato country the united states
could put military bases there and it's
an entirely different set of concerns
from i either want to make more money or
i want to expand my nation yeah and this
would be like the last point if they do
think that the u.s are going to build
troops up there and they do think nato
is going to join then they're like we
have this short window that we have to
invade and actually be successful and
it's got to be now um i want to
i want to ask you guys oh god did i just
forget the question i was going to ask
you got it it's gone
it's coming back i actually got a buzz
in my ear on the new world order just
said no no no
so there was a um this video on fox
maybe i should pull it up actually where
this uh actually i don't know if anybody
wrote about it i'd have to find it on
twitter cool i just remembered my so you
can do that um
i didn't know this until recently but in
some polling like 80 to 90 of people in
crimea wanted to go back and be a part
of russia and i know people have said
like oh the russians
specifically sent people to live there
to try and make it a russian majority
and have that happen but then they've
got the same thing in dunes where there
are a lot of people that want to be a
part of russia
do you think that they should be allowed
to have some sort of
vote referendum like quebec did in
canada to join russia or is that a
problem okay i wanna reasoning and
self-determination
but people are saying it's malicious and
russia russia's specifically sending
people there so like
let's look at open borders groups if
they specifically had a bunch of
um mexicans go into california and then
said we want to have a referendum to see
if uh california wants to be a part of
mexico how would you feel about that
uh well put well i mean i gotta be
honest that's that's war that's a type
of war tim would say california they can
have it yeah
even though the things california is
known for are basically useless they do
produce what they're not known for is
useful which is producing food yeah a
lot of almonds too yeah uh well
here's here's the question though
the the the issue with
the uh don bass region dinettes gluhonsk
what some people have told us and again
i know it's fog of war propaganda it's
hard to know what's true is that uh it
was ukrainian and then during the soviet
union holodomor russification the
eastern regions became predominantly
more ethnically russian as opposed to
ukrainian now 30 years on all of a
sudden it's like well there's a lot of
russians people you know speakers here
guess russia should take it
i guess the question is how fair
how far back do you want to go
yeah what what is the you know
what is the issue here with with the the
eastern region of ukraine
if it was the soviet union if there was
an empire it collapsed there are some
questions about boundaries and borders
and stuff sure california is a little
different if california is allowing
people to come in as non-citizens and
then you know they have kids who then
become citizens and within 18 or 20
years they vote for secession you've got
a serious question about whether or not
there's an intentional act to come in
and take take land away from the united
states
that being said there's still an
important question of if they if they
play by the rules if they're working
within the law if these people are
citizens and they vote to secede and
join mexico
do we do we respect the wishes of
secession and this country was founded
on a bunch of people being like we
hereby vote you know we like we're not
part of the you know the royal the
british empire anymore and britain was
like nah and they fought over it so
maybe that's what happens is like
both sides will claim they're right
whoever has the has the ability to
defend themselves or reconquer the land
you might say like they have like some
ethical
justification to say we're going to be
part of mexico now but realistically the
us government's not going to give up
their west coast all that water
well that's that's why tim brought
warfare into it too it would be a
question of would mexico be be capable
of going to war with the united states
military and the answer to that question
is almost certainly no unless there was
an ally in another part of the world who
wanted to send their troops in to help
so china said let's destabilize the
region and
you are you are wrong oh i am wrong
explain you got to understand man um
with what we're looking at in russia
a bunch of regular people with guns
almost impossible to conquer
oh that's true air superiority does does
nothing for holding for occupying
territory you can't occupy street
corners with fighter jets that's true
vietnam
right
afghanistan now exactly our artillery is
not going to hold down uh it's not going
to force people to you know go to
certain buildings or to not go near
certain buildings certainly you can blow
the cities up okay well sure but what's
the what then what's the goal there so
well if you're trying to conquer or
maintain control of a land blowing it up
and wiping it off the map it's kind of
like well we're losing it anyway let's
cart let's blanket sweep and just wipe
everything out and rebuild later maybe
but you're not going to be able to
control the people here's why i'm still
correct because oh boy because
you are correct i mean firstly a
defensive war is always easier and less
expensive to fight than an invasion is
however
it would depend on what percentage of
california wanted to be a part of mexico
and how many people there would actually
be willing to fight alongside the united
states government to maintain that
territory as part of the us i don't
think it's just a question of the u.s
coming in and blowing things up yeah
it's it's uh if there was enough
sentiment in california for secession
and i actually think there there might
like i said like
around a third to 40 percent of people
in like each of the five regions of the
us are you know favor secession of their
region so uh the question is how many
people support secession how many people
oppose it and how many people don't care
and if you look at uh like democrats to
republicans in california it's two to
one it's like for every two democrats
there's one republican and then
independents are people who are more
likely to say i don't care yeah so
i kind of think that
you'd if it was a
a democrat secession which is what
people are actually talking about and
what you know the podesta what the
boston globe story they were wargaming
out what happens after the 2020 election
if trump won they were suggesting the
west coast secede
it's a it's a it's a left democrat
secession movement whether or not the
united states
can can stop it from happening
i'm not entirely convinced they could
you know we we can talk about you know
what did putin say oh i'm sorry what did
biden say if you want to go up against
us you need nuclear weapons
are you talking about bombing like
civilians populations with nuclear bombs
otherwise
you can't do anything yeah destroying a
country is different than taking and
conquering a country that's why
propaganda is like the most important
thing well it's the entire reason they
want to disarm people
oh yeah absolutely yeah isn't it amazing
watching all of the
like
lefties go full soy over the ukrainians
being armed yeah
yeah and supportive look at all these
normal individuals boss babe with her
gun and i'm like yeah that's cool i love
that but why don't you want that for us
yeah because the second amendment isn't
about oh i want to go to the shooting
range and have some fun or if this
happens i think this might be waking a
lot of people up to that and realizing
like yeah we need to be armed all of us
look at our southern border we should
have access to it southern borders
porous what do we have like a million
encounters last year or more oh yeah and
it would be way more than what we're
counted i you know i was just down there
and i was watching every day i
was like i counted a million i counted a
million myself no i was i i literally
just drove to uh one random part on the
other side of a country club in in
mcallen texas stayed there one morning
at 4 am got out of my car and there were
traffickers walking by and they're like
don't film this dumbbell mess and i'm
like holy like you can just drive
anywhere across the border and see
people making a little journey
nice wild
how can you what electric fence is can
we do something like that's inhumane
okay so here was the issue is there was
a texas country club there was the wall
and then it just stopped and there was a
texas country club i guess they couldn't
buy the land so all of these human
traffickers and gang members were just
going through this country club on the
side of mcallen
country club didn't care
i guess not because they're so they they
just go up they go around 4 a.m they say
there's uh shift switches at that time
with the border guards and they're just
kind of lazy and
you know a little more lethargic so
they'll just go across at 4 a.m go
through the night this is this is why um
mentality culture psychology is so
important for a war effort if the united
states it has a has a large quantity of
people who don't care about their
borders
and even the people employed to guard
the borders don't care about the borders
then yang got a border absolutely and
then you i mean so so you know we got
into talking about this because of the
issue of the eastern region of ukraine
where you have people voting to to you
know be annexed by russia or to succeed
or whatever in crimea that's basically
how russia gained control of it they
were like oh we had a referendum and
everybody voted
there was a poll from several years ago
like well before the annexation and it
found that it was the most pro-russia
portion of ukraine that they basically
were like we're russia we're not ukraine
but we're legally ukraine so i can
believe that a lot of people there want
to be part of russia i don't know if i
believe the referendum was legit you
know i mean like putin comes in he had
tanks ready and then it's just there
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there